hospitalisé depuis le 22 août dernier
dans un hôpital berlinois alexeï navalni
semble répondre aux voix des médecins et
commence à respirer sans aide extérieure
pourtant rien ne dit si l'opposant russe
pourra ou non
retrouvez ses facultés de langage tout
cela dépend de la manière dont l'agent
neurotoxiques a affecté son système
nerveux car s'il a effectivement le
système nerveux endommagé et le cerveau
est bien évidemment lié au système
nerveux
il lui sera très difficile d'expliquer
de parler de ce qui s'est passé de dire
comment à son avis il a été empoisonnée
etc
il nous faut attendre il faut attendre
le rapport des autorités médicales
allemandes pour comprendre ce qu'il a pu
dire et à qui il a dit si la
communication avec lui était tout à fait
logique et s'il parle couramment en
attendant le fait que navalni soit sorti
du coma semble confirmer qu'il n'a pas
été empoisonné par nos vies de choc
comme l'indiquent un des concepteurs de
cette substance
le professeur léonie drink à l' agence
ria novosti alors que la russie est
pointé du doigt par l'allemagne dans
cette affaire dmitri peskov porte-parole
du kremlin réfute ces accusations
il faut quand même rester lucide en
évaluant la situation
je répète une fois de plus que pour nous
toute tentative d' associer la russie où
les autorités russes cet incident sont
inacceptables elles sont intrinsèquement
absurde
le 3 septembre dernier alexandre
loukachenko le président biélorusse
avait dit détenir une bande-son
impliquant varsovie et berlin preuve
selon lui d'une falsification de
l'empoisonnement d'alexei navalni
diffusé à la télévision publique
biélorusse l'enregistrement est
fortement remis en doute par les
autorités polonaises et allemandes
nous démentons les informations rendues
publiques par la biélorussie selon
lesquelles il y aurait eu une
conversation téléphonique entre varsovie
berlin au cours de laquelle les
autorités des deux pays auraient
confirmé qu alexeï navalni
n'avait pas été empoisonné tout comme le
gouvernement allemand
nous condamnons cet acte honteux nous
estimons que les auteurs de l'attentât à
la vide alexeï navalni doivent être
tenus pour responsables
ces allégations de monsieur lukashenko
sont naturellement fausses et la
transcription de cet exposé fictif que
vous pouvez lire le week-end dernier n'a
pas changé notre opinion de son côté le
porte parole d'angela merkel fait savoir
ce lundi que la chancelière allemande
n'exclut pas la suspension définitive du
projet de gazoduc nord stream de donald
trump a déclaré qu'il soutiendrait
l'annulation du projet ce chantier
cofinancé par plusieurs groupes
européens représente plusieurs milliards
d'euros d'investissement